an investigation is underway in New
Jersey after police punched a young
woman in the head while trying to arrest
her over the weekend cell phone video
shows one officer pinning 20 year old
Emily Weinman down while another officer
hits her several times
officials in Wildwood New Jersey claimed
Lymon was drunk on the beach and kicked
an officer in the groin she said she
told police she was not drinking but
made no public response to the kicking
claimed Wyman faces several charges
including assault the officers involved
are on administrative duty pending the
outcome of the investigation not a
typical Sunday at the Beno